[Music]
please welcome to the inbound stage G
[Applause]
[Music]
vaynerchuk
morning um yeah so I'm really excited to
be here uh I have a whole bunch to talk
about um but first i'm gonna ask you
guys a question to allow me to figure
out what direction I should go with uh
my talk how many people here are fairly
familiar with me and my Spiel raise your
hand and how many are
not
[__] bad
start um okay that's kind of what I
thought though actually so I'm going to
uh I'm going to uh give a little bit of
my backstory I apologize uh for a lot of
the people that have heard this but it
creates such a context to the things
that I believe in and I'm passionate
about and more importantly I think we'll
really round out the entire story so
I'll go a little faster than normal
because luckily and I appreciate a lot
of you do know this um but since there's
more of you that don't I'll start with
this I was born in uh in bellarus in the
former Soviet Union my family immigrated
to the United States in 1978 when I was
3 years old uh we lived a very very very
ghetto immigrant lifestyle uh I lived in
a studio apartment in Queens New York
half excuse me a fourth of the size of
this stage and uh with eight family
members including my crazy crazy great
grandmother so it was pretty intense um
it was one of those things where my dad
worked a bunch of side jobs and I never
saw him I actually didn't know my dad
until I was 14 because he worked so much
he left before I woke up and got home
after I went to sleep one of the side
jobs he got was in a liquor store in
Clark New Jersey and he used to commute
from Queens to Clark and uh he was a
stock boy my dad's first four words in
English were Budweiser Mad Dog 2020 and
Boon's
farm so you know kind of Great American
Dream stuff my dad worked really hard
and we eventually moved to Edison New
Jersey I uh started my entrepreneurial
career in Edison New Jersey I uh I had
seven lemonade stands um do you guys
remember big wheels those little bikes
you like
those I used to ride my big wheels
around Edison New Jersey and picking up
my cash from my friends that worked the
lemonade stands like I was little Tony
Soprano or something um it was a good
gig good business I did well and then
when I turned 12 I started my first
really big business uh when I was 12 I
was selling baseball cards at the malls
and and Convention centers baseball
cards got really big around that time I
was making2 to $3,000 a weekend selling
baseball cards when I was 12 years old I
don't know about you guys but when you
have $30,000 in cash under your bed and
you're 13 and you're not selling weed
you're doing a good job so I was excited
about that that was awesome I as a
matter of fact in hindsight I don't
think I've ever been more Rich than that
moment I mean you really do not know
what to do with that kind of money when
you're 12 um bazooka is like five
[__] cents
um so that was that and I was rocking
and I wanted to build the biggest
baseball card business in the world I
wanted to open up 500 locations of
baseball card stores that was going to
be my life I was set I didn't care about
anything else I didn't care about school
I didn't care about girls I wanted to
build this that was it that's who I was
going to be and then when I was 14 my
dad ruined my life I was getting ready
for the biggest card show of the year it
was at the Ron Expo Center in Edison New
Jersey $ th000 table it's like the thing
I I prepaid for the table I'm getting
ready in the morning I'm pricing my Ken
griffy Junior rookie cards I'm super
pumped and my dad walks in and goes
you're coming to work now and I'm like
Dad I think you're mistaken I got the
biggest show I'm not sure how many of
you up in the rafters have Soviet
fathers but I lost that argument you
have a Soviet Dad let's talk later to
nice nice Russia represent um
so I lost that argument which was
devastating we lived 45 minutes from the
liquor store at that point so I cried
the entire way down it was devastating
and uh finally with about 2 minutes
before we got there I asked my dad how
much he was going to pay me I composed
myself he said two bucks an hour and
then I really started crying and that's
how my Wine Liquor business career
started for the next year and a half of
my life um I went into my dad's store
every single weekend every single
holiday I walked directly into the store
and went directly into the basement and
bagged ice for 13 hours a day for two
bucks an hour it sucked
[__] how many of you have seen the movie
The Goonies please raise your
hand I was like Sloth from The Goonies I
was chained to the basement by the way
I'm devastated Cindy didn't sing The
Goonies song did she the the other night
crap anyway side note I uh I hated it I
wasn't your normal teenager I didn't
care about liquor and beer I I just
didn't and finally when I was 16 and
finally allowed upstairs something very
interesting happened probably the reason
I'm standing in front of you it was a
normal Saturday kind of summer day the
wine spectator had just named c special
select 1990 the Cabernet the wine of the
year and every single person was coming
in and asking for it and after about 20
people coming in and then leaving
because we didn't have it I decided I
was going to take a back order we didn't
have a back order system in the store
but that didn't matter because I was
going to school on Monday anyway so I
wouldn't have to deal with the aftermath
and so I said the next person that comes
in I'm taking a back order because this
is ridiculous guy walks in do you have
the C no sir I'm like how many you know
uh let me take a back order he's like
sure I'm like your name add dress I'm
like how many bottles would you like he
says I'll take six cases I said oh [__]
an alcoholic I go six cases I go are you
having a party and he said no I collect
wine and that was it because I was so
passionate about baseball cards and
sports memorability and all that stuff
that connection to me was humongous I
was like I remember do you know when you
like hear a song or or smell something
you can like literally like rewind in
your mind to a moment as I'm telling you
this I don't know if you guys can zoom
in straight Goosebumps I literally
remembered that moment so so vividly I
was standing in the middle of the
Chardon a section in my dad's store and
I remember saying to myself huh Wayne
Gretzky Michael Jordan Ken griffy
Jr Silver Oak
cist Opus One same [__] I can do this so
I literally literally took all my effort
of learning about like statistics and
sports and that and started learning
about wine and decided I wanted to build
the biggest wine businesses blah blah
blah here's where a story starts
mattering for you guys and and makes it
worthwhile for you guys to be here this
morning I always thought I'd open up
hundreds of stores hundreds of baseball
card stores hundreds of liquor stores
it's how you built businesses when you
were doing to consumer in the 80s and
90s it's just how your brain worked when
I went to school my freshman year in
college the next moment that changed and
shaped my life the the theme of my talk
which is we are living through the
biggest culture shift of our time and
you've talked about a lot of things
during this conference and SEO matters
and social matters and all this stuff
matters but what I want to talk to you
guys about today is what really matters
which is how substantial this culture
shift really is how many dollars are
really in play and why all of us
including me standing on the stage are
grossly underestimating what is really
going on let me explain I was playing
Madden 94 against my roommate dominating
him by the
way and my friend walks in and goes you
have to come and see this I am standing
in front of you as somebody who's made a
lot of money and been successful and
continue to hope to be successful around
technology but I stand in front of you
here today and I want everybody to
understand this the only reason that I
love and adore social media is because
it sells
[__] let me say that again the far
majority of what I'm going to be talking
about for the rest of this keynote is
going to sound very very very very
Mother Teresa and I am not that the
reason I'm doing this is because this is
where I think the cash is going the
reason I believe in this and put all my
effort into it is this is where I think
the customers are going that I want to
tell my story I don't give a rat's ass
about [__] Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram or any of that
horeshit what I do care about and what
every one of you should care about
whether you're B2B or B Toc is where do
the customers ATT tension go and if
you're not there and you're not playing
properly within that you're going to
lose and so we are living through the
biggest culture shift and I realized
that on this magical 1994 day because in
1994 at the age of 19 I still have never
had a computer in my life as a matter of
fact I'm not even sure if I've ever yeah
I did I played like Oregon Trail and
some [__] class once I basically
never used the computer at 19 years old
I was writing my papers on a word
processor my friend runs in and says you
got to come and see this I'm like let me
finish winning this Madden game I
finished winning that Madden game I run
into this storm room and I hear the
following thing my friend is sitting in
front of this thing and he clicks some
buttons and I
hear remember that [__] remember paying
13 [__] dollars a minute to be on the
internet [__] AOL anyway it's another
story so hear this thing right we were
getting do you guys remember that bill I
mean there's some youngsters In This
Crowd you guys don't remember we were
getting killed out there my friend signs
in he goes into this chat room he types
in as
slsl another
classic and he looks at me cuz he's
sitting and I'm up here I'll never
forget this look for the rest of my life
he looks at me and he goes we can get
chicks on this
thing
and as long as I let the pause just
happened now while you were laughing
because that made me feel really good by
the way thank you was about as long as I
paused before my brain said I can sell
[__] on this thing and that was it my
life changed again right there and there
I waited like 7 hours after every person
sat down and tried to get chicks and
thought they were getting them and I it
was like 3:00 in the morning and I
finally got to sit down in front of it
I had no idea what I was doing but
somehow I found a baseball card Forum
within AOL and it was just very obvious
to me that this is what was going to be
the game changer of my life I started
like reading about the information Super
Highway and all this stuff the internet
was here and it really [__] with my
brain and I realized right then and
there I wasn't going to open up 600
liquor stores I was going to do
something on this thing I launched wine
library.com in 1997 my dad's liquor
store was called Shoppers discount
Liquors I didn't want that I wanted a
brand I wanted to build something and I
launched wine library.com in
1997 I went on to run that organization
from 1998 to 2004 or so 2005 day-to-day
in that five to six year span I took it
from a three to a $70 million business
and I did that strictly on one thing
Innovation see I launched wine library's
email service in 1999 but I didn't
realize it what I knew was this when I
think about sports which is something I
care a lot about especially football
which makes me sick that I'm here this
weekend in the precursor of the Jets and
Patriots season but we'll talk about
that another
time I really hate the Patriots I'm
sorry I'm
sorry um yeah I know I know you guys
know I really hate the Patriots
um all right break out of it um so what
what I know is this that when you think
about where the business World goes
you've got to innovate and we're living
through a huge Innovation platform right
now I launched my my email service in
1999 without realizing that it was an
email service here's what I knew like
the sports reference speed kills right
speed kills and what I understood was
that my competitors were putting out
cataloges once a quarter and sending
them into the mail and letting people
buy wine that way or if they were really
innovating they were faxing their wine
offers remember that thing they were
faxing their wine offers to their
clients and then there's this email
thing do you guys remember the first
time you found email I want you I want
to take you guys back to that moment we
loved email when it came out I remember
looking at it and saying say wait a
minute I'm never going to write a letter
again I'm never going to buy a stamp
how's the post office going to stay in
business subsidize but that's another
story
but that was a game-changing moment I I
I know for a lot of parents in the crowd
here your kids went to school that was
the first time you got to stay in touch
I mean this was a game changer we loved
email how do you guys feel about email
right now we hate it you know why and
this hurts because I'm standing on stage
as a
marketer I know we're talking about the
love of marketing let me make one
statement Rafters pay attention
especially that dude all the way up
there dude pay attention to this [__]
statement you
ready
marketers ruin
everything it is what we do it's what we
do we ruin everything it's our job we
see something shiny and we squeeze the
[__] sh [__] out of it until we can
get as much cash into our pockets it's
how we roll and that's [__] great I
just want to make that statement right
now so you understand that everything
I'm going to be talking about for the
next 45 minutes everything I'm going to
be talking about for the next 45 minutes
has about a shelf life of about 36 to 48
months gut feel because we're going to
then ruin everything I'm about to talk
about and then we'll find the next thing
Google Glasses will come out we'll start
[__] with that [__] figuring that out
you know it's all going to happen right
but everything I'm going to talk about
right now will be ruined by us
collectively and that's just the way it
is and that's fine now speed kills so I
launched the email service and it was
great I launched it it was the weekly
Wine Library email service and you know
what happened I sent an email I started
collecting it this is 98 99 97 you do
not realize how far we came this is how
it worked people would walk into my wine
shop you have need this great I'm like
you should join our email service oh
yeah cool I think I I just got one of
those great what's your email pen and
paper pay attention what's your email uh
I think it's AOL
yahoo.com I mean that's where we were
lucky for me Wall Street was fairly
early with email we were in a place that
was very close to that so people
actually had emails but it was really
crazy like people didn't really know but
here's what I know we hadn't ruined
email marketing yet so my open rates
were up my open rates were like
86% I mean like stuff that you can't
even imagine go look back at 1994 Banner
ad click-through ratios when you have
time you'll see numbers like
87% I mean if you're like 0 87 you're a
genius now like I mean think about that
so like marketers ruin everything that's
great and that's what we
do but my email service really mattered
and at first it was the weekly email
service and it was great and it did
tremendous and people would open it and
buy it and then I got smart and said you
know what I'm going to do this the
bi-weekly email service right and so we
did that and that worked and then then I
did it every day 5 days a week and that
worked and that kind of is the way we
stayed for a while and our sales
exploded and then one day driving to
work on a Saturday I said to
myself people open email on Saturday
right and so we did that and that worked
but then you have the diminishing return
see there's something really interesting
going on right now in the world that not
enough of us are talking about you've
spent a lot of time during this
conference and you spend a shitload of
your time thinking about customer
acquisition we think about customer
acquisition in a B2B or a b2c world at
enormity and when you think about some
of the sites that have been successful
in B2B or b2c business their acquisition
is great the tool that is the foundation
of this conference is unbelievable the
tool is getting better and better in the
release that just came out ridiculous
the tool is phenomenal but with all due
respect to HubSpot if you guys suck [__]
at using it you're not going to go
anywhere people talk about what's the
ROI of social media all the time to me
what's the
ROI let me ask you guys a question
what's the ROI getting to the tool
conversation what's the ROI of a
piano let me explain the ROI of a piano
to me is Jack [__] zero I I don't know
how to play it I don't know what to do
with it nothing the ROI of a piano for
Billy Joel and Elton John has been
substantial the ROI of social media to a
lot of people is [__] you know why cuz
99.9% of the people that are using
social media today at this moment suck
[__] at it right you know why because
they're all acting like 19-year-old
dudes if you look at how businesses and
how so many of you and I've been
watching you and looking at the hashtag
some of you are using social media
you're trying to close on the first move
that does not work and so when you think
about what's going on in the marketplace
today it's a very interesting time
because so many people are focusing on
customer acquisition and they're not
focusing on the game that we should all
be paying attention to because if you've
been listening carefully over the last
three days or more importantly what
you've been doing for a living customer
acquisition in an internet world where
we can follow everybody doing everything
is starting to get mapped when you start
understanding what banner retargeting
ads are doing and how efficient they are
to build up list if you start
understanding why zingga or Groupon or
living social or guilt group why they
happened why they happened so fast a lot
of it has to do with customer
acquisition the science the Quant of
that being mapped where I think the huge
opportunity for every person in this
room is not customer acquisition because
I promise you it's going to be a bigger
commodity in five years than you think
the game for everybody in this room is
is the game that's always been the game
but it's super not sexy it's not really
fast and nobody really wants to do it
which is
retention retention is the game My
Friends the game in business is not how
many customers you can get it's how many
you can keep the game for me is not
acquisition it's lifetime value and the
percentage of wallet that I get from
that person we are thinking about things
in a very American way more fast want
and it's great and I love it and that
entrepreneurial Spirit really matters
but I'm telling you right now there are
way too many data nerds that are really
[__] smart that are figuring this
[__] out I knew my Goose was cooked a
couple years ago when I'm the best wine
marketer in the world at the time I
don't [__] care if you felt like that
was an egotistical statement I was the
[__] guy right I could write an email
and [__] sell and crush and kill
every time and was dominating and then
one of my developers came in in and said
uh Gary I think if you make the add to
car button orange instead of blue we'll
get a huge lift and I was like [__] you
[Applause]
nerd I was like nerd you don't tell me I
know the customer you [__] hit those
buttons dick
but but you guys know what happened
[__] was
right pissed
still
we are now living digitally we are
tracking we are watching we're watching
every move there's a little secret that
nobody's told you we collectively don't
give a [__] about privacy they want to
tell us we do but we don't you know why
you know what the most under marketed
best brand in the world but is
completely misbranded and is the
shittiest brand and the worst marketing
towards but is the best thing in the
world human beings
the news and the things that you guys
consume have convinced you we're bad
meanwhile if you look at the data were
obnoxiously good it is stunning by data
how few bad things
happen but when they happen you know
about them every night we're pounded all
the bad things the
0.00000000 1% of us do remember when
Myspace and all these social networks
came out remember when this all came out
and the kids were going to go to the
malls and they were going to get raped
because of Myspace remember that whole
story do you know what's really
happening do you know what's happening
in our society crime and child crime and
kidnapping is going down do you know why
because all of us are media
companies because what technology is
doing and social is doing is we're
exposing the shadows of our society it's
kind of hard to steal a kid now when
every [__] is doing what you guys are
doing right now with your phones you
can't get away with it and so we're
living in a very interesting time we're
living through the single biggest
culture shift of our time and we
completely disrespect it we talk about a
lot of the tactics but when you really
understand what the tool that you guys
are here on this arena for what that
leads you to and then what you have to
do with that tool then you start really
understanding where business is at let
me
explain culture shifts how many people
here by show of hands have reconnected
with
somebody that they had not talked to in
5 years because of Facebook raise them
don't get
lazy almost
everybody how about 10
years look at that almost
everybody 20 give it to
me guys 70% of this room has reconnected
with another human being that they had
not talked to in over over 20 years
because of the growth of social media
let's let's also take this moment to
understand right now one thing I hate
the word social media hate it you know
why because it confuses people remember
when we called all this [__] Web 2.0 six
minutes
ago we need to call things things
because it makes it easier to talk about
I'm cool with that where I'm concerned
about is all the people that are
debating if social media is good or
worthwhile or most importantly and all
of you are thinking this and I get it is
it worth all the
time because the thing with social is if
you want to do social right there's no
automation there's no Auto retweets
there's no Auto DMS there's no
automation social is human so it takes
time humans time is expensive so then
you start debating the ROI I get it but
to debate the validity of social media
is nuts because the word social media is
only a word that is referencing the
current state of the internet to bet
against the internet in 2012 is a really
really bad idea I don't think anybody's
walking around and you know what's nuts
is anybody willing to today is anybody
willing to stand up right now this would
mean the world to me is anybody willing
to stand up right now honesty is the
greatest thing on earth you're not going
to want to say yes to this but I'm
setting you up is there anybody in the
house that is willing to honestly stand
up right now and I want you to stand up
that remembers saying the following
thing in
19967 this is going to be tough but if
you said it please because the truth is
the greatest thing in the world please
stand
up who here between the years of 1995
and 1999 said that the internet was a
fad stand
up holy [__] I found
him sorry give me one
second good thing I've been working out
otherwise i' be tired how are you man
good what's your name Chuck Chuck let's
give it up for Chuck's honesty first of
all
Chuck so you remember fundamentally
thinking like we'll be on this thing for
a couple minutes but then it'll be over
I was 14 at the time I had uh a very
close friend who was obsessed with AOL
he spent all this time on chat rooms and
playing games and looking at porn right
and uh I figured you didn't like the
porn part well that part I could see the
appeal but but it just sucked all this
time and I didn't I didn't see it as
anything being really productive I mean
I was only 14 at the time and I'm
thinking you know my God there's so much
other stuff out there and this thing is
so damn slow and slow damn expensive you
know I mean I get
it did you think that Twitter was the
dumbest thing you ever saw when you
first saw it actually no you you felt I
was one one of the first people to sign
I was say able to get my full name got
it sign so how many people in this room
don't lie lying is the devil how many
people in this room the first time they
saw Twitter thought it was the dumbest
[__] they'd ever seen good everyone just
me and you didn't chuck thank you so
much let's CL it up right
here I need to get a belt
um here's why you all thought Twitter
was the dumbest [__] you ever thought
because you're marketers and your
business people and you know what we do
when we look at things we looked at
Twitter and we said wait a minute who
gives a [__] if I'm eating a
pizza right you looked at Twitter and
you
said that's the dumbest thing I've ever
seen what am I going to
say that's where the whole thing breaks
that's why so many people are
underestimating what's happening right
now the same reason almost all of
you thought that Twitter was stupid is
the same reason that people are
struggling to understand how big and
powerful this thing really is because
all of you looked at Twitter and said
what am I gonna say and I said holy [__]
I can see what people are saying and
engage it and that's why I love Twitter
when I looked at Twitter and more
importantly when sam.com came out and I
could search every single thing that was
being said on Twitter when I searched
the word wine I could engage I didn't
act like a 19-year-old dude I didn't
come in and say hey Sally I see that
you're talking about penal GRE we have a
sale on it no I said you're drinking
penio are you nuts that [__] is
whack [__] Pino
ggio how many people in this room love
Pino ggio raise your hand don't be
scared so for the 150 of you please do
me a favor Suave s o a v half the price
don't buy the bowl of suave in the big
bottle don't be cheap go for like the $8
to12 Suave for from Italy 2010 vintage
really strong you will stop drinking the
PG horeshit
okay we defaulted into saying what are
we going to say because we want to sell
I'm telling you guys if you go
counterintuitive on this whole thing the
upside is dramatic I am thinking about
writing a new book the title is called
jab jab jab jab jab jab jab jab jab
right
hook and by the way Harper Collins If
you don't let me put in all those Jabs
I'm not writing the [__] book
dicks you're killing
it [__] it I'll just go
direct
so culture shifts right culture shifts
we are living through the biggest
culture shift of our time and it's
happening because almost all of you have
reconnected with a human being that you
hadn't talked to in 20 years now let's
talk talk about what's really happening
the attention and eyeballs of the end
consumer no matter if you're doing B2B
or B Toc the only thing you want to do
whether you're apple or you're a firm
right now trying to get to three
specific buyers because they represent
80% of the market no matter if you're
that or if you're Apple the biggest
company in the world you myself and
everybody in between we're in the same
business one thing we have a story to
tell and we want the atttention of the
consumer to tell
the person that's best at getting the
attention combined with telling the best
story converts the best yes there's
other things and landing page
optimization that's all important that's
part of the story if you think about the
marketing aspect of it it all matters
whoever tells the best story to the
people wins where are our eyeballs and
ears going that to me is the thing that
I'm completely obsessed with right now
where are we spending our time we are
spending our time more and more on
social sites on other places that don't
look like the places we used to how many
people in this
room use a TBO or DVR or on demand or
Hulu to watch the far majority of their
television please raise your hand Oh
weird
everyone how many people in this room
have not consumed a single television
commercial in 2012 because of this
modern technology please raise your
hand an enormous amount if you think
about it how many people taking out live
sports and the [__] Grammys have not
consumed a commercial this year more
meanwhile the far majority of my clients
at Vayner media are spending 80% of
their budgets tens of millions of
dollars on reaching you through
commercials yet you're not consuming
them how many people here do direct mail
for their business please raise your
hand it's good I I do too don't worry
raise your hand I always find to be a
funny question because a lot of people
do it but every time I ask it you should
have seen what just happened how many
people here do direct mail and this is
what I
saw how many people here feel that they
consume direct mail that when you come
home and you open your mailbox you love
all that dog [__] that's in your inbox
how many people how many people consume
it hardcore that's good good [__] nice
you like it catalog go through It's
Entertainment fair when you think about
the cost of that delivery or more
importantly my favorite example of
traditional marketing versus new
marketing how many people
here are really giving thought to the
one thing that I think Oprah Winfrey is
most right about in the entire world
which is when you leave here today do
good old Gary one favor a lot of you
going to be traveling home a lot of you
going to be traveling back to your
apartments when you're driving in the
cab or your car I want you to look at
four people while you're driving while
you're in the car remember this keynote
look at four people while you're driving
I guarantee two of them are texting it's
dangerous out there I have not driven
this carefully in a long time because
I'm really paying I feel like I'm 17
again I'm really paying attention
because two of them are driving so in a
world where two out of every four people
that are driving are clearly texting
while they're
driving why are we spending billions of
dollars on outdoor
media guys we're living through culture
shifts people are not looking at
Billboards they're not even looking at
the [__]
[Applause]
road then you think about display ads
right you think about the ads do you
know that there's an interesting study
I'm looking at right now I don't I hate
to quote it because I haven't done all
the homework but the basic thesis is if
you're 24.6 years old you basically are
struggling to see the right side of a
website because that's where the ads
have always been you've fundamentally
trained your body to not see it right
right and think about I mean we I think
a far majority of people here are doing
some sort of sem or display advertising
or have played with it or have seen it I
mean think about what are the accepted
click-through ratios you know could you
imagine living in a world where less
than 1% was considered [__] awesome
[__] right but they work and they bring
value and I get it but when you start
thinking about the movement right now to
Native ads integrating it to the things
that BuzzFeed is talking about share
through we're living through a very
interesting time we only care about
breaking through and then telling our
story and here's what's happening here's
where it all ties in we are living
through a stream economy every person in
this room and more and more of our
customers are now living through a world
where they do this where they do this
and it's fast and it's hard to tell
stories there and all of a sudden micro
content really matters all of a sudden
being in this room and understanding
that if a video on Facebook is over 10
seconds it doesn't do as well as if it's
9 seconds that shit's going to start
mattering because here's the most
important picture I want to paint you
when the television came out Barbie put
out a commercial one of the first
commercials you know what the commercial
was it was the dude that was doing the
radio ad sitting in front of a camera
reading the radio
ad that was it that was the commercial
you know why because there was this huge
culture shift and there was a new
platform and what they did rightfully so
because it's what we do is they put what
they thought worked there on to here and
figure it work clearly that is evolved
but what I see going on in Social today
from a day-to-day basis is people doing
the Barbie commercial on television we
continue to do things on there as if
they were
websites as if they were a banner
campaign as if they were copy or print
mentality and we're living in a world
where we're living in a stream economy
whether it's Pinterest which is a little
more like this Facebook a little bit
more like this Tumblr Instagram we're
living through a speed place where we
want to tell our stories and so how do
you break through two ways tremendous
understanding of micro content and what
that means and where that's going but
number two the thing that I love the
most if content is King and we've all
heard that context is God the word that
every person in here is going to care
about over the next 10 to 15 years is
context we are now getting more data on
people than ever before you know why
you've all reconnected with people that
you hadn't talked to in 20 years you
know what they're saying on
Facebook Snickers are
delicious we've all agreed that the
music industry has been disrupted right
we've all agreed that you know you don't
buy CDs anymore you buy one song at a
time you don't buy in bundles disrupted
Napster iTunes disrupted we all based on
what I said about my next book you guys
reacted we can all agree that publishing
is on its way to being really disrupted
right direct to Consumer on your iPad
your Kindle disrupted the one thing I
implore you to think about on this talk
the one thing I beg you and I'm gonna
get I'm gonna I'm gonna sit down because
it's is a very big moment this really
really really really matters to me and
if and if I can get this across Then I
then we've
won the one thing that we are not
talking anywhere close to enough about
is that Comm communication has been
disrupted the way we communicate as
human beings has been
massively massively fundamentally
disrupted and changed there are grown
ass men in this room that texted in the
last 24 hours the following thing
OMG do you remember how many people here
have are parents have nieces or nephews
or something that's somebody that's very
important to them them in the ages of
now uh 15 to 22 please raise your hand
quite a bit of you do you remember three
years ago this conversation maybe
four when you rolled up on Little Ricky
and said Ricky I don't give a [__] how
you talk to your friends but when your
father calls you pick up the [__]
phone remember
that just curious how's that working out
for
you
and it's not because little suie or
Little Ricky were so smart it's that
they had technology on their side some
poor sap bought 10,000 horses the day
Henry Ford created The
Car Technology doesn't give a [__] about
you or me it's just going to continue to
move and change and we are living
through the biggest shift ever let's
talk about B2B for a second we are now
living in a world where you could figure
out exactly who you're looking for to
sell to by going into LinkedIn now
because of the way LinkedIn has been
evolving could change a little bit with
where Twitter's evolving you have a
great opportunity to actually see who
the person is in real life see we have
data and you guys have data on business
on who people are as a customer you know
what they spend I know a shitload about
you if you're a wine customer of wine
library.com from a wine standpoint I
know that you drink [__] Peno gregio
right I know you do X Y and Z I know
your average spend and where you live
but what I don't know is who you are see
what's Facebook did was it mapped the
social graph but if you're paying close
attention to what Tumblr and Pinterest
and Instagram are doing right now
they're starting to map something that I
think a lot of us are going to be
playing in over the next decade which is
the interest graph my friends I'm
telling you right now the interest graph
really matters here's why you can know a
whole lot about me but if you know that
I love and live for the New York Jets
then you have a much better chance of
selling me and so anybody in this room
who's a sales person or as sales DNA
knows the more you know about the person
the better shot you got it's why you
take them to dinner it's why you take
them to the ball game it's why you do
those things that face to face time but
now what's happening is we're living a
digital life we're sharing more things
on the phone and to the public than we
ever did before we're saying things on
the Social Web that we would have never
picked up the phone and called our
friend about nobody in this [__] room
picked up the phone 10 years ago and
said Pinkberry yogurt's
delicious but you're all doing that now
and what that does is creates context on
who you are and what you like and if you
use that I mean to think about how to do
business in a B2B world today it's so
[__] easy Jesus you go to LinkedIn
you find out who the [__] is then you
find them on social you watch what they
like and you reverse engineer the whole
thing it takes eight seconds let's do it
I mean it it sounds ridiculous and
sounds fast but it's actually the way
it's doing we as a BC retailer now we
are trying to map every single person's
Facebook and Twitter account for our
Wine Library customer base for one
reason we want to know who you are so
that we can jab jab jab jab jab jab
right hook you we just sent somebody
tickets to a barbecue festival in Kansas
City because we knew that he liked it
the end the tickets cost me more than
the profit I've made on him so
far but guess what knowing from other
stories he's about to tell 437 people
about it and you know what that's called
customer acquisition because what I like
to say is something I love this saying
I'm curious if this is going to be the
most retweeted
one I set that
up I really like this though it
capitalizes exactly how I feel as our
world goes more Jetson the business
people the marketers and business in
this room that act more like The
Flintstones are going to win see what I
know looking at all your pretty faces
right now is that every one of your
grandparents was more prepared to be
successful over the next 20 30 years
than you are you know why because they
really gave a [__] and you know want to
hear some bad news you don't you don't
you do but you don't you can't help it
as much as you think you do you don't
because
effort effort for your
enduser is such a limited thing our time
is being spread into so many more
directions now and time is such a
valuable asset that you can only build
so much you know hard day there's only
24 hours in a day and so effort we have
a massive effort supply and demand issue
right now people want effort which is
why when a company is brilliant as
we love price it's why Walmart and
Costco and all these things work right
we live on price but because they give a
[__] we're willing to pay more oh my God
they ship us stuff back and forth no
[__] [__] they're charging you for
it but you love it right you love it and
that's great that's great marketing
that's great storytelling that's great
execution and they found what people
cared about were willing to pay more I
mean I've literally had people tell me
they're much happier to play this is a
true survey that we did for Wine Library
people are happier to pay more in total
in their wine for the year more in total
if we charged them more and gave them
free shipping want it and I'm like [__]
you why but they want it good we'll give
it to you I mean that's what's so
interesting understanding where Market
shifts are going what they care about
let me give you a free shipping story
supply and demand culture shifts I did
free shipping for the first time in Wine
Library 1999 it is still one of the
biggest days in Wine Library history we
are 15x the size of what we were back
then but in 1999 free shipping from an
internet company was rare it caught
people off guard we sold so much wine
over that 8 day period I felt like
people were buying wine that week like
they thought the Cure was inside of
these [__] bottles right I didn't
sleep me living in the thank you economy
back then had a interesting moment some
guy bought a bunch of wine and in the
comment section my guy in the order
Department did a great job he knew I
cared about like this he said in the
comment section he said um thank you for
doing this this is incredible I just
bought this wine for my daughter's
wedding me living in the thank you
economy back then call him and say Jim
thank you so much for the order can you
please tell me the date of the wedding
and where it is I've got a really
special bottle of champagne I'd like to
send for you and your daughter to enjoy
he replies oh no no no no my daughter's
Gary
I said what he goes yeah my daughter's
12 years old but this is such a sick
[__] deal I'm going to put the wine
in the basement and
[Applause]
wait now we're all so collectively
spoiled we don't buy [__] unless it is
free shipping consumer expectations
change and let me tell you one dirty
secret about social that's going to [__]
with all of us if you don't give effort
to your customer you're going to lose
you know why because of Social and
because it's scalable effort is much
more scalable on the internet with these
platforms a lot of people are going to
see a lot of people want to talk about
what's the ROI of social media or all
these new sites what they're not taking
into account is the dilution of the
other platforms do you know that I have
not gone to Google to search anything in
the last year like I just don't go there
I don't go to Google Now yes I have a
lot more followers than the average
person so for me to tweet or Facebook a
question or thought is a lot easier but
I don't go there you know why do you
guys remember Google in 1999 2201 do you
remember that remember when you never
went past the first or second result it
was that good remember that thing what
happened marketers ruin everything right
we started filling out meta tags and all
that [__] and figuring it out and gaming
it so we're living through that now
ironically and this thought is not fully
fleshed out which is why I'm only giving
you a sneak peek of it because I don't
want to be that on the record but when
you start thinking about well Google+ is
doing I'm actually man this is going to
hurt I'm actually pretty bullish on goog
plus let me explain goog plus I don't
think is actually a social network it's
a social network API it's a layer I
started seeing some stuff that kind of
blew my mind imagine a world where you
search for wine on Google and on the
right side is my profile and my latest
status update because I have the most
social equity in the wine space so we're
living through a place where things
continue to change and what I know is
this humans like to buy from humans we
want to have a relationship you have to
care about the end user because somebody
else is going to because the tools are
being put in place through amazing SAS
products like we've got here and other
things in out there just the public data
the data is now out there for the first
time to be able to have a relationship
with the end consumer and it really
really matters and more importantly
understanding who you're selling to
matters more than ever we living through
a time right now right this second where
Innovation is happening so fast I don't
know if you guys saw this but the travel
websites the top travel websites are now
getting more traffic on their apps
collectively than their websites and
that's mobile and.com together what does
that mean that changes the game I mean
we're living in a world where this thing
is the precursor to the robot that we
were all promised remember that robot
that was going to clean your room in the
80s this thing is now that what happens
in a world where we're paying for
everything with this what happens in a
world where the kind of apps that are
going to be built are going to be on the
technology this for example here's where
I think innovation's going I want to
lose 10 pounds I'm going to have an app
that's going to help me to do that and
when I have to go pay for something at
Burger King because I'm running through
the airport and I'm hungry when I go to
pay my app's going to tell me to go eat
a [__]
salad we are living through the single
biggest culture shift using the tools
really matters you being here makes me
realize that you understand one of the
best tools in the marketplace and you
know what you have to do what concerns
the living [__] out of me is that I
think you think the tool is going to do
it for you the Tool's going to get you
to the place but you've got to execute
and the execution is hard the execution
is hard the way you scale social is
human beings it just is the automated
our [__] Radars are incredible do
you know how good our [__] Radars
are remember this trick in email
marketing remember this this one when we
started figuring out we could put the
person's name in the
beginning you know how uh you know how
you feel when you get an email from
somebody and your name comma is in a
different font and color than the rest
of the
email you want to punch the [__]
screen with your neck
right [__] that hurt
actually our [__] Radars are greater
than ever the kids that are growing up
today and our future customers they've
been marketed too from the second they
started breathing unlike some of us
their [__] Radars are better than
ours authenticity really matters it's
hard to scale that it takes a lot of
Manpower a lot of hours there's a lot of
cost to that the tools will get us there
but understanding what to do with that
data is the entire game I am shocked we
do something at Vayner media called
surprise and Delight where we map our
customers and our own employees interest
graph it's quite easy you look at what
people are taking pictures on Instagram
and you you know what they're into you
look at what they're talking about on
Twitter and you know what they're into I
am blown away that and this is like and
this comes from me being a really
hardcore salesman so I can feel it I'm
Blown Away by how many people want to
figure out the best tactics on SEO the
best landing page optimization the best
this that and the other thing and are
completely lost that everything happens
after they swipe their credit card with
you for the first time everything
happens in year two and three the
problem is it everybody's treating
social you know this one doesn't go over
so well with the ladies so first of all
I just want you to know the top
Executives in my company are women my
mom is my favorite person in the world
but this is the perfect analogy and this
doesn't mean I'm talking about you I'm
probably talking about that girlfriend
of yours you know that one I'm talking
about
ready this is how I see people looking
at their business right now and
especially social I actually have a very
dear girlfriend a friend that is a girl
that
uh fundamentally put dramatically more
effort into her wedding than she has
into her marriage
and it's not even close and as I look
around the room I saw a lot of people
shake their head I think when you look
at the marketplace and how big weddings
have become and how that industry has
become that there's a lot of people out
there that are spending more [__]
time on planning their wedding than the
effort that they're putting into their
actual marriage that is what I feel is
happening in marketing as well so many
people are worrying so hardcore about
the tactics that you've learned over the
last three days they're not paying
attention to what happens next what
happens next my friends is going to be
the whole [__] game do you know why
because if they're teaching you this
conference they're teaching it at 40
other conferences the tactics are
[__] commodity your effort and how
much you give a [__] about a customer
isn't if you learn how to scale that and
how to afford that you will win going
forward because the Collision of
people's [__] Radars what they
expect from companies and expectations
and the fact that the commodity of
everybody being able to get to everybody
through the same means are colliding
which leaves one thing who's going to
care more about the and user how are
they going to scale that and in a world
where we're only going to have 20
hundreds of a second to reach people
because no longer like the 1970s do we
sit down 80% of us and watch [__]
happy days and then don't get up and go
take a piss or make popcorn and watch a
commercial the new Proctor and Gamble
that day is over and the days of me in
1998 getting people's emails and getting
86% open rates because nobody else
[__] emailed spam them are over and
do you remember 36 months ago when you
[__] loved Groupon and Living Social
CU you couldn't [__] wait to get $40
worth of sushi for $20 you remember that
how do you feel about those [__]
sites now you hate them cuz they spamed
you into a [__] Oblivion and you
don't give a [__] about spa treatments
anymore so as awesome as that feels and
as much as we clap it up you're doing
the same [__] in your business and so am
I we're doing the same tried and true
it's converting we understand the math
but what we never look at is the
diminishing returns see life's funny
right you see something happening and
you're like that's a terrible [__]
move right because we don't know what
would have happened otherwise you just
don't know that's what I'm hoping Heaven
Is by the way I can't [__] wait when
I die if I get up there and it isn't
where I could watch my whole life and
instant replay and then say well what if
I did this and then see the outcome I'm
going to be [__]
pissed anyway sorry went off a tangent
there I'm just super hot on that theory
it' be so [__] cool like oh [__] holy
crap if I left four minutes later I
would have met Kean Johnson amazing
anyway you know what working because
you're looking at the data but T the
data my friends is the post game
intuition and common knowledge of what
consumers want and what you want as a
customer impos into your business really
matters understanding that in a world
where we are getting pounded with
information I mean no wonder our kids
are add right I mean you hear the Eric
Schmidt quote bless you you hear the
Eric Schmidt quote of the amount of data
that we're creating now in every 48
hours is equal to the amount of
information we created from the
beginning of mankind until
2003 I want you to hold the hands of the
neighbors next to you because this one
matters that much I'm going to repeat it
again the amount of information that we
you guys aren't [__] holding hands
please a little something something it's
nice it feels crazier than you think
doesn't that feel nice do you guys know
each other and now you feel like you
know each other a little more right yeah
best the amount of information we
created from the beginning of mankind
when we're [__] pounding Dinosaurs
the beginning until 2003 which was like
16 minutes ago that Collective amount we
are now replicating in every 48 hours so
what do you think is going to break
through your [__] landing page yeah
it is at times if you know the funnel
and you this that the other thing but
I'm telling you with all my heart it is
a clear indication if you pay close
attention to what's working you've got
to build a brand otherwise it's a
tactic you've got to build a brand
otherwise it's a tactic and the brands
that are going to survive going forward
are the ones that are behind the
backbone of effort because all the other
stuff that you talk about and all this
other stuff that this conference has
been about you're going to do it anyway
you know why when push comes to shove we
get desperate and we start converting
I'm just trying to shift you a hair just
give give me a [__] inch give me some
give me uh give me something because I'm
telling you the residuals that are
tremendous now what's really most
interesting to me is that we can now
track it a lot better in 19 in
2001 it
snowed in New Jersey uh on December 23rd
which was the one of the busiest days of
the year typically December 23rd is the
busiest day of the year in a liquor
store um and a woman called us which
just started shipping and her case of
Behringer white zendel wasn't
delivered first of all I appreciate the
people that know what baringer white Z
is good
job the entire case by the way 15pack
the entire 15pack
case cost
$45 we're doing
about $40,000 an hour in the store she
calls I find out about it somehow it was
buzzing cuz I was the floor selling I am
the premier salesman on the floor as you
can
imagine I find out about it and we're
debating what to do she needs it for her
Christmas
dinner I grab the case throw it in my
car and drive to Bergen County to
deliver it it takes me two and a half
hours to complete the whole thing the
woman was 194 years
old we didn't have a lot of lifetime
value on the back end
there
she looked like [__]
[Applause]
Yoda and the best part was I delivered
it all pumped with myself and she said
great and close the door
awesome everybody especially my dad who
was pissed that I left because all the
customers that came in asking for me or
that I could have sold everybody's
baffled I can't tell you what the ROI of
driving through the snow in my car to
deliver a case of $45 pink [__] to a
woman that looked like Yoda
was but I can tell you this over the
next two to three years that story
became the foundation of how we treated
every single customer it became our
Competitive Edge and those are the
things that matter to me I love black
and white data I'm obsessed with it the
day when the nerd beat me I [__]
understood that the Nerds beat me and I
respect the living [__] out of data
conversion funnels all that [__] but I'm
telling you right now that there are way
too many [__] running businesses
today with this and not enough people
running businesses with
this and again I swear on my life I am
not Mother Teresa and I far from run my
business just on this but I'm telling
you right now the reason I amassed my
following the reason
why I continue to retain it is because
my percentage of this far outweighs
every [__] in this room I mean it
that's how I feel and that's how I try
to roll every day and I promise you if
you are able to figure out how to
afford how to afford the allocation of
this in your business more your
long-term value will be dramatically
higher your longterm business success
will be dramatically higher your
grandparents your great-grandparents
built businesses based Bas on this it's
how we built the whole thing we got
really lean and mean when we went to the
suburbs and big box stores and all we
cared about was dollars and it's great
and the data matters and continue to use
it and use this tool and understand it
but I'm asking you one final thing when
you go home if this talk meant anything
and by the way I fundamentally believe
only three of you are going to act on
this talk I do because what I talk about
is ridiculously hard and massively
frustrating and takes forever you know
like everything that's good in [__]
life
if you do anything because of this
keynote there's only one thing I ask you
to do because as Zen as I got I'm a
practical [__] here's what I
want from you when you go home look
yourself in the mirror and audit
everything you and your business do I
promise you that if you audit from top
to bottom of expenses and effort and
time and energy and payroll and all that
[__] if you audit all of it even the
best of BU even the inbs which is the
company that bought Budweiser they built
their whole business on like printing on
both sides of the paper and all that
horeshit even the most efficient ones of
us are doing 20% dumb [__] if you take
that 8% that 133% that 16% of dumb [__]
that you're doing paying that person
that's not bringing any cultural value
to your business having that contract
that you've just been in and you just
renewed because you're busy as [__]
whatever the [__] you're doing if you
take any piece of that percentage and
you apply it to giving a [__] about your
customer it will be better for your
business going forward because For the
First time since we all lived in small
towns where your reputation was the
complete backbone of how you did
business for the first time because
technology is bringing us back together
in a small town for the first time being
good and caring and following up matters
it [__] matters how about doing
something random act of kindness for a
current customer not the ones that
unsubscribed or left you know how you
always do nice [__] when they're going
how about while you you've got them
reallocate your thought process I'm
telling you because the tools that the
is the umbrella of this organ of this
event are getting so good so good you
know what that means all that shit's
about to become a
commodity emotional EQ is going to
dominate business over the next decade
and I implore you to start paying
attention and oh by the way I'll leave
you with this you know what the best
[__] part is it feels good
thank
you thank
you so nice thank you so
much thank you
guys thank
you thank you so much
guys thank you so
much